يعني رغم التصعيد من الطرفين الغربي
والروسي بخصوص مساله الردع النووي الا ان
المعارك على الارض بالاسلحه التقليديه
الثقيله والخفيفه منها تستمر
وتشهد يعني ارتفاع بوتيره الاعمال
العسكريه لنبدا من باخ مضحكه همم شمال
مقاطعه ثانيه بالفعل ما زالت قوات فاجنر
تقاتل في محاور عده اهمها المحور الجنوبي
بعد سيطره المقاتلين على همم بلده كلشبكه
تتقدم نحو العمق الجنوبي الغربي الى مدينه
اوبلده ايفانكا من اجل السيطره وتوسيع
الطوق ليشمل ليس ناحيه الشمال الجنوبيه
فقط الجنوبيه الغربيه همم تسعى القوه
الروسيه في ذلك المحور ايضا من منطقه
سيلدار من المنطقه الشماليه الى التقدم
نحو مدينه سيفر وقد سيطرت على بلده صغيره
همم يعني قبل بلده سيفرسك وتطوق بلده
سيفرس من ثلاث نواحي والحديث عن التوقي
يكتمل ليصبح اقل من دائره كامله ليس نصف
دائره بل اقل من دائره كامله ليدفع القوات
الاوكرانيه للانسحاب قبل الحصار الكامل
بالفعل همم في كل عمليه عسكريه هناك همم
اقتحامات من قبل اجانب الروسي همم يخسر
الطرفين في هذه الاقتحامات قتلى واصابات
لا يذكر اي من الاطراف عن خسائر بل دائما
همم يعني الدفاع الروسيه تحدث عن يعني
تنحيتها لاعداد من الجنود الاوكرانيين
وتدمير الاليات العسكريه تطور المعارك وصل
الى المناطق الجنوبيه حيث مقاطعه زاروجه
بالفعل تتقدم القوات الروسيه همم كل يوم
من ثلاثه الى اربعه كلمترات
سيطر على بلدات سيطرت على بلده اريحا
خضراء فريق هنا قصف اوكراني وهجمات مرتده
من الجانب الاوكراني لكن القوات الروسيه
تقدمت لتسيطر على كيلومترات طويله نحو
مدينه زاباروجي حيث تم يعني تموقع القوات
الاوكرانيه همم ايضا تشهد المناطق
المتاخمه لمدينه
افديفكا معارك ضاريه الجيش الروسي او
القوات المتطوعه لو يعني لو لو قلنا
المتطوع لان كثير منهم بعقود خاصه يدخلون
الى هذه المعارك بالفعل تتقدم وتدفع الجيش
الاوكراني للانسحاب همم الى الناحيه
الغربيه طبعا هذه تعتبر شمال غرب مدينه
كما ان مدينه افديف كي يحاول الجيش الروسي
اقتحامها وسط صمود للقوات الاوكرانيه
وهجمات مرتده في بعض الاحيان امس عاده
القوات الاخرانيه امطرت على نقطتين كان
الجيش الروسي يسيطر عليهما القصف العنيق
مستمر في ساعات الليل الطويله وفي النهار
همم يوم امس خلف ثلاثه اصابات هنا في
مدينه دانيت منذ الصباح حتى الان اصابتين
خمسه اصابات حتى الان المجموعه النهائي
همم اجانب الاوكراني يقصد بصواريخ امريكيه
الصنع وقذائف امريكيه الصنع منها ايضا همم
اوروبيه مثل التشيكيه والبولنديه همم ربما
ان همم الذخيره عند الجانب الاوكراني حسب
المراقبين هنا خالد قد نقصت لان الايام
الماضيه كانت اعداد القذائف والصواريخ
بالمئات يعني 300 400 و500
الحصيله اليوم امس
111 قذيفه وصاروخ هذا يعني بان يعني حجمها
القصف الاوكراني او كثافته خافت بينما
هات الروسيه تقصف ب 10 اضعاف